so ben looking at your imdb you were
born in 1988 right
you loved john hughes movies and
john hughes was already making films by
this time where does this love for 80s
films come and do you feel you were born
at the wrong time i
used to say in the past that i was born
in the wrong time because i used to love
the 60s so much
but as i grew up i just
i think it was like five or six years
ago i just fell into this love for 80s
movies like i mean
my all-time favorites are john carpenter
william fritkin
john news these kind of people who use
the genre the genre of film as a way to
convey a story to
as as a starting point to just
tell
a bigger story i love how and the
current brothers are still doing that
for me the
are still doing kind of an 80s
genre
kind of
cinema and i love the way in the it is
the genre was a starting point to tell
much bigger stories story with political
implications or metaphysical
implications
for me i remember the movie gotcha i
don't know if you remember
anthony edwards and even though it was
about a serious subject there was still
an element of play right and i missed
that about so many films that's that's
so true i mean uh especially the the
blockbusters and the studio movies in
the 80s used to have this playfulness as
you were
saying which i think uh relates to i
mean nowadays we are we are in a
postmodern age where
i mean a lot of filmmakers are kind of
obnoxious
by making movies
because some of them are aware of that
but i think that
some of them are
not because it's also we live
in a time where i mean we have
cinematics and places where we see a lot
of movies
old movies uh all the time and i think
that
cinema of course is becoming more and
more an art and we are restoring
preserving movies and it can be
cumbersome sometime because we feel like
we are staying standing on the shoulders
of of giants you know of the people
who came before us and that's true that
i loved the 80s movies in a way because
they were so playful and they were
so
not pretentious at all i mean when you
look at back at the
the the
the blockbusters of the 80s they were
not so pretentious and that's why i
think like a movie for example like
guardians of the galaxy right now is
doing so well at box office because it
has this kind of
um
not i mean not rebel spirit but i mean
it has this playfulness and this
uh not pretentious aspect to it even
though i even though you
you can like it or
not like this movie but you have to
recognize that it has this playfulness
that
hollywood cinema and blockbusters used
to have in the 80s it seems like two
there was a lot of cameos right people
and sometimes they weren't even really
stars they were just known yeah for
being like in movies and like you never
really knew what they did yeah but so do
you do you miss that do you think i mean
we still see it somewhat today but maybe
with you know a musician but is that
something that also treats you yeah i
mean i i mean we were talking about
januz uh
i it was not in breakfast club i think
it was it was in ferris bueller the
cameo of uh charlie sheen i mean is is
amazing it's like i mean the image of
chelsea in this perfecto
leather you know jacket is like standing
in the camera it's it's so
it's so funny and and he's on camera for
like
five or ten seconds no more and yeah i i
love this idea of
coming back to john news and these kind
of directors who had this group of
people of actors following them and just
working with them and they could call
them and just propose them a cameo just
a small thing into a movie right do you
want to bring that back i mean i think
in was it staying alive sliced alone
bumps into john travolta and like the
opening shot you know it's so great yeah
is that something that you want to
incorporate just there's an element of
play even though it was a sort of
serious film stainless yeah i i love
this playfulness and for me it was uh
it's something i i love
these blockbusters back in the day where
this playfulness this
this game with the
the audience and this way of just
getting the audience in and playing with
them
along yeah so
i think nowadays it's sometimes a lot of
bloodbrushes and and even indie movies i
mean a lot of movies right now i think
are
really
sometimes too
um
too aware of what they are doing and
it's like
they have to make references and they
have to be serious like
and i mean i love i mean for me the line
of the joker and the in the in crystal
and the dark knights like why so serious
it could be it could apply also to movie
making right now it's movie making is
getting
i think too serious i mean it's like
it's so serious you want to say like
make some joke i mean
take take
take a joke and just laugh at it i mean
to make the process even more fun for
the audience so yeah i think we lost
will i mean we lost the fun part of
making movies i mean a lot of people
lost it and you can feel that in the
movies
you